our next grand guest has a play-to-win
attitude
that makes her all the goals
at the age of 59 debra houston is a
mother
and grandmother to six and a
great-grandmother to three
but what makes her stand out even more
well she just made history as the oldest
soapbox derby racer in
the country that's right here she is
it's debra
[Music]
hi drew hi debra
i'm so excited to meet you and i'm
excited to meet you too how did you
end up getting into soapbox racing
well you know indianapolis is known for
the racing
and a friend of mine had approached me
about taking my grandchildren to do the
soapbox racing
and um so i thought it would be a good
thing for
them to get them off the computers you
know it'll teach them responsibility
and you know give them something to do
during the pandemic so
i took them to practice and they met
their coach mr larry
and mr larry kept approaching me about
racing
he said you the perfect size
he said come on do it and i i kept
thinking about it thinking about it and
i finally said okay i'll try it
i love it because i mean
i i learned that like the oldest soapbox
racer
in your team is 14 right
right i just love
this this is so cool tiny but mighty
now yes what was going through your head
the first time you were like well
at first i was i was a little nervous
and i was hyperventilating because i
wasn't so
nervous and i i went down that hill
and when i went down that hill i said oh
i can do this
i can do this and i started practicing
and kept going down that hill
and it turned out to be fun i i was
at the same time i was going through
chemo so
i said well you know rather than sit up
and work and worry about chemo i could
be practicing and having fun
and you know just doing this with my
grandchildren and
i really enjoyed it and
is it true that you're doing
fantastically well
now yes i am cancer-free
yes i'm i i asked that right away when i
found out and it's just so important
and your story your attitude the fact
that you want to get your kids out of
the technology and out into the world
during the pandemic
the fact that you had cancer and were
going through this but chose to spend
your time
doing and focusing on this you are the
example
thank you girl thank you thank you true
puppy
you are what's next for you what else
are we gonna learn from you
well i'm gonna i'm gonna go race this
2021
and this year i'm gonna win so
it's to race and to win in 2021
well you are the biggest winner
and we want to be cheering you on and i
have a little something for you
oh really for me yeah this is um a
little
name yeah it does um i hope you don't
mind we put a little logo of our show on
there
here you go that's a racist suit and
it's
just perfectly your size and i will say
it's sturdy but it's also really soft
oh my goodness thank you thank you drew
it is such a pleasure
but that's not all check this out so
we know you live in indianapolis so we
reached out
to the indy 500 when they heard about
you
they wanted to give you a few things as
well so
they want to have you wave the green
flag for the indy 500 practice day
yeah that's right oh my goodness
oh my goodness how cool is that and they
also
really cool oh that just makes me feel
so good
thank you well they also want to put
your soapbox
on display in their fan area on
actual race day and host you and all
your grandchildren
on practice day and show you off
like a little debra museum thank you
so much thank you
oh deborah do you mind if we speak to
you again and ask you
how that day went and you know just
check in
yes oh you can please call me please
call me
please please call me i'm
i need more i want to like catch up and
see how that day went and
um thank you to the indy 500
who gets it wants to honor deborah we
honor you here at this show we love you
and i can't thank you enough
for being here to uh be that example
oh thank you drew and thank you for
having me and thank you for all of that
thank you so much
oh thank you deborah